une place aux matchs des idées
internationale ce soir échanges et
analyse avec anthony bellanger et
nicolas tenzer en a parlé rwanda on va
parler russie on va parler navalni mais
on va d'abord s'arrêter sur l'info du
jour à l'étranger c'est la mort du
président tchadien idriss deby il serait
décédé des suites de blessures après une
opération militaire il dirigeait le pays
depuis 30 ans il était l'allié
indéfectible de la france au sahel c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs un tournant
géopolitique pour la région et même pour
l'europe dans sa lutte contre le
djihadisme on va aborder tous avec nos
invités d'abord les premiers éléments
avec fleurance aux vaches
à peine réélu dès le premier tour des
élections pour un sixième mandat
le président tchadien idriss deby est
mort ce mardi des suites de ses
blessures au front il commandait son
armée contre les rebelles dans le nord
du tchad
lorsqu'il a été blessé dans les combats
c'est avec une profonde amertume que
nous annonçons au peuple tchadien
le décès ce mardi 20 avril 2021 du
marshall du tchad idriss deby itno des
suites de cette blessure au front
à 68 ans ce militaire de carrière
s'était emparé du pouvoir par les armes
en 1990 régulièrement accusé par les ong
internationales de violer les droits
humains idriss deby était considéré
comme un partenaire essentiel de la
france dans sa lutte contre les
djihadistes au sahel d'un allié de
confiance et qui a toujours apporté
notamment à travers
à travers l'opération barkan qui est une
opération difficile compliqué vous le
savez bien et on a eu souvent l'occasion
de s'exprimer sur ce sujet c'est un
allié de poids qui va nous manquer c'est
une difficulté supplémentaire en tous
les cas qui se présentent à nous dans un
communiqué l'elysée déplore la perte
d'un ami courageux et insiste sur la
nécessité d'une transition pacifique et
rapide
l'assemblée nationale et le gouvernement
ont été dissous en attendant des
élections libres et démocratiques qui
seront organisées à l'issue d'une
période de transition de 18 mois d'ici
là c'est le fils du chef de l'état
défunt qui dirigera le pays est avec
nous pour en parler ce soir dans ce
match des idées nicolas tenzer bienvenue
vous êtes président du centre d'étude et
de réflexion pour l'action politique
directeur de la revue le banquet
spécialiste des questions stratégiques
et internationales et enseignant à
sciences po
anthony bellanger face à vous bienvenus
journaliste et chroniqueur éditorialiste
internationale à france inter
la france perd un ami courageuse et la
réaction de l'elysée qui est d'ailleurs
un petit peu tardé après l'annoncé de la
mort d'idriss deby anthony bellanger
c'est un ami mais plus que ça non bah
oui c'était c'est le dictateur de la
république
enfin vous rendant dans ce coin là on
peut pas dire les choses autrement il
est installé depuis trente ans au
pouvoir il a été maintenu à bout de bras
plusieurs fois pouvoir parler par le
gouvernement français qui est intervenu
même directement
il ya des soldats français installés aux
hommes aux alentours de commander à de
n'djamena et même là là là l'état major
de barkan n'y a pas de soldats et
soldates barkan c'est pas il n'y a pas
de forces spéciales le force qui décolle
depuis le tchad pour aller bombarder où
nous intervenons annoncé l'état major
qui se trouve là c'est quand même déjà
important non c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment le le corner les lignes
l'allier
l'allié indispensable alors certains
vous diront on a toujours on dit
beaucoup
l'armée tchadienne c'est énorme cette
arme est absolument vrai extraordinaire
mais c'est vrai que c'est une des
meilleures d'afrique c'est une de celles
qui intervient le plus fréquemment ces
dunes c'est aussi celle qui s'est le
plus battu c'est à dire qui a le plus
d'expérience mais par contre ce qui est
je pense qu'on fait une petite confusion
entre la garde présidentielle
une quête une garde prétorienne autour
du président et l'armée tchadienne
elle-même qui souffrent par ailleurs des
mêmes maux que le reste des armées
africaines de la région c'est à dire
qu'elle est quand même beaucoup moins
bien équipés que l'armée présidentielle
que là que la garde présidentielle
elle est aussi liée il y a en son sein
des divisions qui qui recoupe les
divisions ethniques et des divisions
territoriales
il ya aussi des jeunes j'ai des jeunes
militaires dans au sonar méfaits à
tchadienne qui se posent des questions
et qui sans s'opposer toulon notamment
du processus électoral qui a conduit à
la réélection entre guillemets disaient
les débits cité il ya quelques jours où
on peut parler réaction la renomination
la halle à l'arrêt institutions de d
idriss deby donc c'est pour ça que ça me
conduit à dire que la solution qu'on a
tourné court ce soir ne sera pas celle
je peux vous l'assurer de l'avenir du du
chat r non je ne pense pas que le fils
du président déby monsieur matte dégrise
débit 37 ans succédera à son père ça
n'existe pas les dynasties en afrique
cette espèce de 2 comment dire de de
gendt qui a été mise au rapidement à la
tête d'air amène à la tête du pays
à mon avis ne devrait pas faire long feu
c'est une prévision encore une fois les
prévisions en afrique sont toujours
battus par la réalité
ça dépend aussi de l'intervention de la
france et de son et sa volonté
d'interdire ce qui est sûr c'est que la
france se trouve dans un embarras
maximum c'est ce que j'allais lire c'est
quand même un décès qui déstabilisent
profondément la france on a eu la
réaction l'elysée on a eu la réaction du
ministère des armées paris perd un allié
essentiel dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme au sahel et on a évidemment
l'inquiétude de jean yves le drian par
elle paris appelle à une transition
d'une durée limitée
oui
c'est facile de le dire maintenant
encore une fois je le vois pas comment
la france pour être être fait d'eux de
roi dans cette région sûr qu'il va
s'appuyer le doit reprendre un certain
nombre de contacts voir kylie a derrière
il ya quand même des influences
étrangères évidemment extrêmement
importante dans la région et jusque
auprès des proches de l'ancien président
et puis on détourne l acteur
déstabilisant c'est d'abord un facteur
déstabilisant en raison quand même de ce
qui a conduit à la mort dit très ému
c'était krumm je dirais une attaque de
forces rebelles qui étaient extrêmement
puissante forte au point effectivement
que président ci soient engagés c'est
une réalité et ça veut dire aussi que
quand même c'est un pays qui est aussi
menacé qu'il est toujours depuis
longtemps d'ailleurs par des mouvements
de rébellion qu'il est quand même très
difficile de contrôler la préfecture
mans il ya eu au delà de la mort
d'idriss deby il ya eu un succès
militaire des forces tchadiennes zone de
rebelles ont été arrêtés et d'autres ont
été faits prisonniers et c'est très bien
mais quand même je lis il faut
s'interroger sur la situation durable de
ce pays sur ces conditions de sécurité
alors même que c'est un élément clé dans
le dispositif barca alors ce qui est
très intéressant quand on regarde un
petit peu la région la sous région c'est
qu'en fait il ya probablement une lutte
de puissances étrangères dans le coin
c'est à dire que quand on regarde un
petit peu ce qui se passe on voit qu'en
centrafrique pays frontalier avec le
tchad
autour du président s'est constitué une
espèce de 2,2 camarilla pro russe et
notamment avec l'intervention de l'ags
mer on voit que les troupes qui ont
attaqué au nord de la libye
donc ces fameux troupes qui ont eu
raison de 10 rhys débits sont elles
aussi ont-elles aussi été entraînées par
par wagner et par les dons car on voit
la main de la russie derrière mais pas
seulement la main par wagner les troupes
du général haftar ce qui est quand même
un compte qu en règle générale after est
a par ailleurs soutenu par les français
enfin en partie on voit au mali une
junte qui a pris le pouvoir et qui elle
aussi a des liens privilégiés avec la
russie de ces principes aux putschistes
revenait de moscou ou du moins son
talent explique à moscou ce qui ce qu'il
faisait
on voit bien qu'il y a là une lutte de
puissance moyenne d'un côté la russie
qui essayent grosso modo par des coûts
de récupérer l'influencent qu'elle avait
perdue dans que dans la région et si
possible de saper l'influencé française
et qui parvient très bien et de l'autre
côté la france qui était embourbé depuis
huit ans dans une guerre qu'elle n'a pas
forcément voulu qu'elle essaye de suivre
et qu'elle ne maîtrise plus elle a son
principal allié le tchad kiné qui est
qui est en train de s'effriter en tout
cas qui vient de perdre son président
qui vient de perdre son président est là
le mali avec une junte au pouvoir une
transition politique dont on peut en
tout cas en partie penser que la qu'une
des unes des gambiens une des promesses
et de discuter avec une partie des
djihadistes ce que ne veulent surtout
pas les français qu'il ne reste plus que
la mauritanie au fond parce qu'on oublie
toujours la mauritanie et l'autre pilier
militaire solide de la région et qu'il
est parti de la mort d'idriss deby ne
posent pas question est ce que les
circonstances de son décès ce qu'on peut
imaginer que ce soit une sorte d'
assassinat commandité en attendant non
jeunes aux professions non là je pense
qu'effectivement ce serait donner dans
le complotisme dépenses effectivement ça
lui résister assassiné par jeunes très
bien je pense que vous le dire de
manière très claire
encore une fois c'était un combattant il
y est allé lui même voilà et puis dans
ce genre de choses d'ailleurs pas le
seul à être mort il ya quatre de ses
généraux qui sont morts aussi dans cet
accès est donc voilà mais je plussoie
tout à fait ce que dit anthony bellanger
c'est à dire qu'on a effectivement des
actions de déstabilisation non seulement
par des groupes rebelles contre les
gouvernements en place mais cette
déstabilisation de puissance étrangère
et je me demande ce que va revenir sur
l'ukraine tout à l'heure mais quand même
cela montre quand même bien l'action
offensive du kremlin tout à fait contre
un certain nombre de positions
occidentales françaises notamment
l'afrique mais occidentale de manière
générale
en fait je pense que là dessus il ya un
vrai sujet quand même d'ordre politique
sur lesquels il est très important que
la france et si possible qui est quand
même assez silencieuse dans cette
affaire s'exprime de manière claire et
ya un coup d'arrêt à marquer ça change
encore une fois ceux qui sont quand même
assez absent dans cette région et sur
lesquels on devrait pouvoir compter un
peu plus alors on en bénéficie
pour
un dispositif de renseignement ce sont
quand même les américains qui ressentent
comme et se désintéresser fortement et
je pense que ça c'est un véritable
problème
je pense que ça fait partie des
discussions que nous devons avoir avec
le président biden
de manière tout à fait clair on a besoin
d'eux objectivement c'est très important
ce que voulait dire parce que il ya
vraiment une opération russe qui pour
qui les états unis ne sont pas ils sont
pâles joue pas dans la même catégorie
que les états unis par contre ils jouent
dans la même catégorie de la france
l'armée russe dans sa capacité
d'intervention dans son équipement c'est
l'armée française en terme de budget en
termes de capacité d'intervention au
fond ça correspond en europe à l'armée
française
l'armée russe a un porte-avions la
france à un porte-avions l'armée russe a
une capacité de projection de cinq à dix
mille hommes la france a une capacité de
production de cinq à dix mille hommes
donc on est à peu près dans m et donc ce
que fait la déroute in puisqu'en ce
moment il a été mise à peu au ban des
nations qu'il est en ce moment en plus
on y revient voilà c'est qu'il essaye au
moins de pouvoir date de dante a mené
des batailles qu'il peut gagner et là
c'est la bataille militaire qu'il peut
gagner c'est contre la seule armée
européenne avec laquelle il a il est à
égalité
l'armée française ce qui montre encore
une fois on y volonté de déstabilisation
c'est pas une qualité de prise de
pouvoir d'investissements massifs comme
la chine par exemple en afrique c'est
tout à fait autre chose
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui n'est
pas de la france sur qui n'a pas
d'avenir
mais c'est de la pure déstabilisation
c'est le chaos pour le chaos ça ira
jamais l'oublier non pelées on reparle
de la russie dans un instant je voudrais
d'abord qu'on aborde un sujet très
sensible qui va être au coeur d'un
déplacement des manuels maquereau au
rwanda dans les prochains mois en tout
cas s'il est maintenu et d'une rencontre
à paris en mai c'est génocide contre les
tutsi et la responsabilité de la france
dans ces atrocités qui je le rappelle
ont tué un million de personnes entre
avril et juillet 1994
si je résume un peu les choses on a deux
récents rapports l'un français qui parle
d'un ensemble de responsabilités lourdes
est accablante de l'état français mais
pas de complicité de génocide
l'autre rwandais qui affirme aussi que
la france porte une lourde
responsabilité
on va en parler ensemble dans un instant
sur ce plateau mais je voudrais d'abord
accueillir dans ce match des idées
dafroza gauthier bienvenus vous êtes co
fondatrice du collectif des parties
civiles pour le rwanda
ça fait des années que vous traquer les
génocidaires
votre mari le fait que la responsabilité
de la france commence à se dessiner de
plus en plus clairement est-ce que
d'abord ça vous surprend ou pas ça ne me
surprend pas au niveau des
responsabilités bien sûr mais ce qui est
surprenant c'est que ça arrive au bout
de 27 ans c'est à dire que ça arrive
bien trop tard par rapport aux preuves
dont on dispose et dont vous disposiez
peut-être vous déjà c'est à dire qu'elle
nous en ce qui concerne notre travail
est un travail de récolte d'informations
un travail d'un kg est pour les besoins
de la justice
évidemment 27 ans est trop c on a trop
attendu on a perdu beaucoup de temps
pourquoi ça arrive si tard d'après vous
parce que le rapport rwandais montre
comment la justice française aurait
cherché à retarder certaines procédures
et à dissimuler la vérité vous partagez
cette thèse oui je pense oui
il faut dire que depuis 25 ans depuis 27
ans l'ambiance
un chrono les deux pays et quand même tu
oublies les relations sont était jusqu'à
il ya pas très longtemps été tendues où
il était dans un face à face voilà
ollier clé
oui on peut dire des élus est
pratiquement c'est cette responsabilité
de la france comment vous la définiriez
comment vous la qualifiez est-ce que
vous iriez jusqu'à parler de complicité
ou pas vous non oui clairement tout
d'abord nous on apprends rien en fait
dans les deux rapports lé fait qui sont
relatés
c'est tout ce qu'on a toujours dit c'est
toujours tout ce qu'on a dénoncé pour la
plupart des faits mais ceci étant ça
faisait des faits ouais ça veut dire que
vous attendez des excuses officielles de
la france on sait on sait qu emmanuel
macron devrait se rendre au rwanda on
sait pas exactement quand mes a priori
c'est un déplacement qu'il compte
maintenir
est ce que pour vous il doit présenter
les excuses de l'état français ou pas
alors là moi fameux dépend absolument
pas d'eau mois ce qui lui vaudra non
tout simplement qu'on demande c'est fini
les réparations par rapport à la justice
le seul cadeau qu'on peut nous offrir
cette réparation par rapport à la
justice que nous demandons depuis tant
d'années mais ceci étant si monsieur le
président
présenté des excuses au rwanda c'est
tout à son honneur mais ce ne serait pas
une priorité pour vous on va continuer
d'en discuter en plateau dafroza
gauthier évidemment je reviendrai vers
vous pour vous faire réagir à ce qui est
dit en plateau ces rapports sont quand
même majeurs alors ils arrivent tard
mais il semble montrer une responsable
alors dit moi je commence à être assez
âgées je commence us mais je commençais
très serré l'emmène depuis pour savoir
pour avoir suivi la sphère depuis 25 ans
et pour savoir que rapport après rapport
tous se rapproche petit à petit de la
ligne rouge tracée par la camarilla
autour du président de la république
française de l'époque françois
mitterrand aussi bien militaires que
civiles d'ailleurs c'est à dire la
complicité de génocide
ils ont utilisé absolument toutes les
méthodes pour essayer de sentir et y
compris le mans sont celles fameux
double génocide dont on se rencontre on
dirait que c'est un mensonge le mensonge
l'évitement la non des classifications
et encore aujourd'hui en partie des
archives mais petit à petit les rapports
les uns après les autres se rapproche de
cette ligne rouge cette ligne rouge
on la comprend comprend très bien
pourquoi existe d'abord parce que
beaucoup d'entre eux sont encore en vie
et que il donc et que ça signifie
c'est une qualification judiciaire ça se
peut se terminer cette affaire au
tribunal pénal international parce que
quand on est complice de génocide on n'a
pas besoin de prouver son intention
l'intentionnalité c'est à dire encore on
n'est pas obligé de dire que la même
façon que quand vous vendez des armes un
terrorisme n'est pas obligé de savoir
qui les terrorise par contre vous êtes
quand même complice de terrorisme eh
bien là c'est pareil
un complice de génocide ça veut pas dire
que vous aviez vous savez forcément car
j'essaie d'être commis mais parcours que
vous en êtes complice parce que vous
avez fourni des armes parce que vous
avez fourni des prétextes parce que vous
avez fourni et fermer les yeux parce que
vous n'avez pas enfin de parents fermé
les yeux alors ce que dit le rapport
muscler le rapport donc rwandais est
très intéressant parce que encore une
fois il se rapproche un peu plus mais
tranquillement officiellement de cette
histoire de de complicité il dit la
france a rendu possible un génocide
prévisible je sais pas comment vous dit
quoi quand on dire les choses plus
simplement
donc je pense que il menteries manque
encore quelques-uns de ses rapports
officiels qui viendront compliquer la
chose serait ces deux rapports sont
faits pour quoi ils sont faits pour que
justement emmanuel macron puissent se
rendre au rwanda en ayant accompli
et travail officiel français qui encore
une fois rapproche un peu plus la france
alors j'ai passe pas je parle pas la
france hein parce que la france et les
français c'est autre chose mais au moins
de cette camarilla qui existait au tour
d'après dan au malade qu'est donc
françois mitterrand à l'époque et qui a
court circuité en grande partie c'est ce
que nous apprend d'ailleurs le rapport
français à la fois l'armée française et
la police nationale enfin bref toutes
les instances us sur place et la
diplomatie pour pouvoir notamment en
partie rapatriés par exemple les
génocidaires je rappelle que agathe
habyarimana qui est quand même inquiet
quand même une qui était une est
aujourd'hui réfugié enfants et vit
toujours en france en ce moment or elle
est objectivement elle elle pourrait
faire l'objet effectivement d'une
incrimination pénale
elle est clairement lié à 7 à cette
période génocidaire et que entre la
france et la belgique
alors quand même beaucoup de ces
génocidaires ni son qui sont qu'encore
réfugiée depuis sur ce sujet ce que ça
veut dire qu'elle maniait mâcon doit
présenter des excuses parce qu'il bat
l'ordre moi je pense qu'effectivement
d'abord il faut aller encore plus loin
sur la vérité et je pense que la volonté
du président français de déclassifier
les autres archives en tout cas de les
rendre effectivement accessible celles
qui n'ont pas été rendus publics
je pense que c'est un devoir absolu
notamment celles auxquelles le président
de l'assemblée nationale a refusé axe
est la position du club
ce qui est absolument incroyable
effectivement est tout à fait anormal et
je pense que ça arrive il faut le savoir
deuxièmement on s'aperçoit qu'un certain
nombre d'archivés ont été détruites ou
subtilisé et ça le rapport du clair le
monde très bien c'est tout à fait
inacceptable parce que c'est en quelque
sorte une entrave jeu guerre non
seulement la vérité mais peut-être
potentiellement la justice et ça je
pense que là dessus il peut y avoir
vraiment voilà troisièmement en ce qui
concerne effectivement la complicité
ce n'est évidemment pas moi d'en juger
ce sera le cas échéant un tribunal mais
je pense qu'à un certain moment où il
faudra que la justice soit saisie sur la
base du rapport du clair sur la base
avec qui demande un certain nombre de
manquements qui ont été observés enfin
quatrième remarque ce qui est quand même
très frappant quand on lit le rapport du
clair c'est de voir que certains aient
des schémas mentaux notamment de vision
ethniciste effectivement de l'afrique
était effectivement proposé et on
retrouve ce même type 2
vision chez un certain nombre de pseudo
géopoliticien encore vivants qui les
utilisent encore réellement pour pousser
des théories de finalement les deux faux
les deux parties sont responsables il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas véritablement de
crimes on ne savait pas et enfin
cinquième remarque dernièrement c'est
que il ya eu quand même un grand nombre
d' alerte à ce moment là notamment d'un
certain nombre de militaires et voilà
les deux diplomates et on en n'a
absolument pas tenu compte
mais on a fermé les yeux sur un certain
nombre de fêtes qui étaient des fêtes
qui pouvaient être juridiquement et
pénalement plus exactement qualifié côté
un tout petit mot dafroza gauthier je
disais tout à l'heure que vous traquer
les génocidaires on a une idée vous avez
une idée du nombre de deux personnes qui
auraient été complices coupables de
crimes dans ce génocide et qui vivent en
france
aujourd'hui alors bondir le nombre a
beaucoup mais il faudrait déjà commencer
par les dossiers qui sont chez monsieur
madame le juge d'instruction on est une
trentaine de dossiers aujourd'hui en
cours d'instruction
il faudrait déjà commencer par cela
avant même de continuer tous les autres
génocidaires éventuelles et qui sont ici
en france et on sait qu'il y en a
beaucoup
on peut citer on vient de ce que madame
agathe habyarimana il ya un monsieur qui
est cité est clairement dans le rapport
duclair plusieurs fois il est soupçonné
d'avoir descendu l'avion de d'avoir
participé à l'attentât du président le
rhabille alemana donc qu'est ce qu'on
attend
il est vieux il a plus de 80 visiblement
il est trés même malade non alors pièce
conte à fond qu'est-ce qu'on attend ce
contenu
juste une petite chose est sûre rassure
sur votre site internet sur le site de
public sénat un excellent portage d'un
excellent documentaire qui s'appelle
retour à kigali et qui tient ou c'est
peut-être sur celui d'arte et enfin je
ne sais pas je conseille à tout le monde
parce qu'il est absolument y pose
exactement le débat il pose le débat les
questions les questions qu'ils posent
sont des questions d'aujourd'hui et
notamment ceux que posent le
les questions que pose le rapport muse
et sont posées si dans ce documentaire
remarquable qui est ce que la france a
fait après c'est à dire après le
génocide quand elle a en fait permis à
une partie des génocidaires
l'at-elle permis l'at-elle autorisés à
traverser les lignes a traversé la
frontière pour se réfugier à goma sert
côté aux congolais côté république
démocratique du congo
comment en fait dans sa forme est sûre
on voit comment l'armée française a
continué d'entretenir des rapports avec
les avec les génocidaires de puig main
comment elle a contrôlé éventuellement
mais ça c'est plutôt dans le
documentaire qu'il s'est expliquée elle
a vu elle a laissé débarquer des armes
qui ont permis de continuer à réarmer
certes il y avait il ya pas seulement
une complicité pendant avant la période
du génocide pendant la période des noces
mais après mais il ya aussi merci
infiniment dafroza gauthier d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir d'avoir participé à ce
match des idées pendant quelques minutes
on va aborder le troisième thème fort à
l'international messieurs c'est la
russie la russie embarrassé par le
canada demi l'opposant numéro 1 poutine
est dans un état de santé jugé
préoccupant une commission de médecins
lors est transféré vers une unité
hospitalière pour les condamnés mais
l'un de ses proches dit que c'est faux
qu'il a été transféré dans un camp de
concentration ce sont ses mots
un conte concentration et de torture et
non à l'hôpital son avocate dit qu'il ne
reçoit pas d' aide médicale évidemment
toute l'europe s'inquiète la france
inquiète et en ga merkel a dit s'est dit
extrêmement préoccupé écouter ces jours
ci nous sommes extrêmement préoccupés
par la situation d'alexina vanille et le
gouvernement allemand avec d'autres
travaillent pour s'assurer qu'ils
reçoivent les soins médicaux appropriés
nous sommes très inquiets et essayons
d'utiliser notre influence
nicolas tenzer l'allemagne et l'europe
la france ont raison de s'inquiéter
oui ils ont raison de s'inquiéter parce
que bon d'abord il faut rappeler les
fêtes c'est à dire d'abord c'est que le
fsb pop et services russes ont d'abord
essayé d'assassiner navalni que
deuxièmement évidemment ils l'ont tout
de suite
emprisonné dès son retour en russie
qu'il a été évidemment juger de manière
expéditive
on en avait parlé
et que évidemment il saison il a été mis
dans un camp de détention qui est un
camp de détention qui n'est pas
exactement
disons une prison française une vision
occidentale c'est un endroit où
véritable torture psychologique il était
réveillé toutes les heures enfin bon ça
il faut le rappeler
bonds est donc aujourd'hui il a entamé
donc cette grève de la faim depuis
quelques semaines maintenant
et évidemment pour protester peut-être
que poutine ne va pas le tuer finalement
mais mon inquiétude c'est aussi
peut-être quelque chose au corps pire de
plus graves de plus dramatique c'est
qu'on a en face quelqu'un qui ne soit
plus apte à parler à communiquer à
ressentir on en fasse une forme excusez
moi l'expression une sorte de de légumes
finalement parce que ça les services
russes sera offert alors aujourd'hui on
a cette indignation
c'est très bien qu'ils aient cette
indignation mais faut quand même
rappeler que le régime est quand même
coupable de plusieurs centaines de
meurtres de journalistes de dissidents
de défenseurs des trois jeunes est
derrière il ya derrière quand même une
tradition de crime dans ce régime
d'abord un lien avec le crime organisé
du régime poutine lui-même qui a été
parfaitement exposé documenté dès les
années d'ailleurs de poutine à saint
pétersbourg avant qu'il devienne
président que deuxièmement il faut
rappeler la russie a tué plus de civils
syriens que même dahesh donc des crimes
de guerre massif et aujourd'hui on a un
homme effectivement dont le pouvoir se
moque complètement
et je crois que c'est ça aussi qui est
en cause c'est une sorte de continuité
et je pense que l'homme d'affaires
navalni c'est pas une affaire comme ça
qui survient sur une sorte de terrain
vierge
c'est une affaire qui n'est jamais que
le prolongement de 20 ans d'exercice
dictatorial mais aussi criminel parce
que c'est pas tellement de types
d'intérieur c'est vraiment le lieu du
crime donc il s'agit de la part d'un
président et on a fermé les yeux
on n'a pas eu cette indignation peu de
dirigeants occidentaux alors que deux
dirigeants sinon on parlait des crimes
de la russie en série et je pense que ça
aussi c'est un problème alors qu'on se
réveille aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup trop
tard c'est beaucoup trop tard alors
d'abord c'est pas beau et vous avez tout
à fait raison le souligner et je
rappelle que le dernier mot
vous avez une chose un peu définitive
qu'on a dit sur la russie c'est quand
même beau joe biden qu'il a dit poutine
est un tueur et c'est le cas je ne parle
pas du tout à la légère
le précédent 2 opposant en chef de boris
de me lie poutine boris nemtsov est mort
sous les murs ou là sur la place rouge à
deux pas du kremlin d'une balle dans la
tête probablement armé par rami pourrait
finir par mourir on ouvre douter il n'y
a jamais eu autant d'opposants
politiques en prison même sur la période
soviétique
même à la période où sur les gènes et il
était en prison parce que légitime dans
tout cas la pression internationale à
quoi sert l'europe dans cette
contrairement à ce qu'on pense
contrairement à vous je pense par contre
que la robe commencent à réagir
sérieusement on a vu il ya très il ya
très peu de temps la la la tchéquie
expulsé 18 10 in diplomate russe
on l'a surtout vu de solidarité malgré
tout des autres pays européens à avoir
parce que c'est vrai que face à ces
méthodes de tueurs qui consiste grosso
modo à poursuivre ses ennemis jusque
dans les chiottes comme il le disait
lui-même
c'est ce qu'il disait aussi que c'est ce
qu'ils disent et shenzhen il l'a fait
notamment en grande bretagne
je rappelle en rien la sphère script
alors oui là il a quand même quasiment
mis en danger une ville entière sur le
riz est alors et pendant l'e3 avant les
vidéos qui vend les décors en raison d
un poison immensément mortels absolument
partout c'est une signature russe
première chose donc là il ya très peu de
temps il ya une semaine à peine on a vu
les tchèques aient vu expulser 18-18
diplomate
on les a vus aussi exclure la russie
d'un énorme contrat d'un énorme contrat
nucléaire de centrales nucléaires we
will do il candidate et où il était
presque prêt de l'emporter ça représente
plusieurs milliards de dollars
et ça commence là à être très embêtant
il ne faut jamais oublier que
contrairement à ce que raconte la russie
on va se déporter vers l'asie on va
vendre un peu plus de gaz à la chine
notre avis est neutralisée enfin les
avignon c'est l'europe
le clae la russe la russie ne veut
qu'une chose du gaz du pétrole des armes
et des matriochkas donc
je viens vous acheminez matriochkas mais
c'est pas ça qui fait la vente et de la
russie le gaz le pétrole l'énergie est
un moyen de pression maximum et la
tchéquie tout à fait d'accord sur le
constat nous sommes entièrement d'accord
c'est que quand même on voit les
allemands y compris madame merkel l'a
répété récemment qui défend le projet de
nord stream 2 il ya effectivement une
menace pour l'ukraine qui est une menace
pour la sécurité énergétique de l'europe
en plus n'a pas véritablement besoin ça
il faut aussi j'allais vous dire vous
allez vous dire angela merkel combien de
mois 3 mois 4 mois
ok ça s'est terminé 6 e sont les verts
c'est très bien parce qu'ils ont une
position
voilà les 6 et l'achète le nouveau
président de la télé vers les verts
allemands ont une position très forte et
son temps en très haut dans les sondages
pardonnez-moi mais le cas navalni elle
n'empêche pas la russie aussi mais ça
c'est un autre sujet diplomatique
extrêmement fort d'accumuler ces
troubles de les déployer
alors selon l'union européenne près de
cent mille soldats russes seraient
postés à la frontière déploiement plus
massif qu'en 2014 lorsque la russie
avait envahi la crim est avait simulé si
vous voulez le problème de la russie
c'est la non le prêt de la russie c'est
qu'elle n'a que des réponses tactiques
et aucune réponse stratégique s'il avec
des réponses stratégiques elle
soignerait ses clients elle ne perdrait
pas des milliards de dollars de contrats
alors que même son économie en entrant
monte en capilotade en ce moment le
rouble et perd de sa valeur
la russie nana ne récolte pas l'argent
qu'elle devrait apporter avec la avec la
avec ses exportations de gaz et de
pétrole le pétrole commence à être aux
en temps de crise mais bien sûr que si
ça fonctionne
larry c'est sûr que c'est moi et bien
sûr que ça fonctionne ou team bien sûr
que si ça fonctionne d'abord que fait
que fait planer un poutine il se dépêche
il a bientôt en face de lui d'un joe
biden qui la traitaient de chuck qui a
expliqué à l'ats poutine qu'il allait
payer le prix de ses interventions aussi
bien en russie en europe mieux qu'en
queue comme mandat aux états unis par le
biais
plus je suis je suis d'accord mais on
pourrait faire beaucoup plus vous voyez
par exemple la liste que proposait
vladimir h horcoff qui est le directeur
exécutif de la fondation anticorruption
créée par navalni il y avait 35 noms de
ligue arc de gens qui sont proches du
pouvoir qui doivent leur fortune
uniquement à poutine y ont des biens aux
états unis en france en europe au
royaume
on peut geler complètement leurs avoirs
et pourquoi compare les empêcher de
venir on peut parfaitement le fait
pourquoi on le fait pas maintenant
jusqu'à quelques bidons d'autres ce car
voilà mais je pense qu'il ya un moment
où il faut aller jusqu'au bout parce que
là ça veut dire que ce sont les
principaux soutiens de poutine les
pourvoyeurs d'argent évidemment aussi au
kremlin qui vont se trouver complètement
asséché et je pense qu'il ya un certain
moment où il faut à lèvres ailleurs il
ne pousse joint il ne faut jamais
négliger la courage et la négation du
peuple russe pour lequel j'ai une
admiration sans borne capable manifesté
par -25° même et y compris tous les ans
quand ça mais il y à une manifestation
qui est prévue en fait dans tout le 21
je pense pas qu'elle puisse être elle
sera aussi important parce que les
forces de sécurité russes ont déjà
prévenu qu'elle taperait dur mais il
faut jamais oublier que les l'état en
russie finissent dans deux cas sur trois
certainement pas mort dans leur lit mais
comment dire au bout d'une pique petites
choses qui parce qu'elle est
fondamentale
la russie n'est pas ne doit pas être
résumée à poutine exactement la russie
n'est pas notre ennemi le régime
meurtrier criminelle de poutine la vie
et rassure ses mots merci merci beaucoup
à tous les deux d'avoir participé à ce
match des idées fin de cette émission on
se retrouve demain à 18 heures et à
22h30 en attendant vous avez rendez vous
avec bonjour chez vous dès 7h30 comme
tous les jours c'est alexandre poussard
qui recevra notamment christian estrosi
maire de nice et président de la
métropole nice côte d'azur je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur
public sénat